Robert had a friend whose mother was a feared and powerful judge in New York City. And at some point, she got sick and had to go into the hospital.
罗伯特有一位朋友，其母亲是纽约市一位令人敬畏且权势显赫的法官。后来，她生病住进了医院。
Surrounded by doctors kind of shuttling in at a teaching hospital, this old lady kind of looks up from her pillow and she says, do you know the sweetest words in the English language? Not being English majors, all these doctors kind of shook their heads. And she said the sweetest words are "don't be afraid, I'm a doctor." And after that, there was nothing that she couldn't get in that hospital.
在那所教学医院里，医生们进进出出，这位老太太从枕头上抬起头说：“你们知道英语中最动听的话是什么吗？”因为不是英语专业的，医生们都摇了摇头。她说，最动听的话是：“别害怕，我是医生。”在那之后，她在医院里几乎要什么有什么。
How smart.
多聪明啊。
Yeah, how smart.
是啊，多聪明。
In the hospital, we give up our normal schedule and sleep patterns. We give up our normal food and clothing. We're in a place that has its own rules and its own language and its own customs. We're not exactly helpless, but often we're not far from it. And in the midst of all this, there is this delicate human interaction which we have to negotiate. And it's one on which our lives, our actual lives, can depend.
在医院里，我们要放弃正常的作息和睡眠习惯。我们放弃正常的饮食和穿着。我们身处一个有着自己的规则、语言和习俗的地方。我们算不上完全无助，但也差不离。而在这一切之中，我们要处理这种微妙的人际互动，这有时甚至关乎我们的性命，真正的性命。
We have to deal with doctors and nurses, and all sorts of other staff. We have to get what we need from them, in a situation where they have all the power and knowledge, and they may not be as concerned with our care as we are ourselves. Robert Lipsyte wrote all about this in his book, In the Country of Illness. When he got chemotherapy, he says, it meant dealing with a lot of different people in the hospital.
我们必须和医生、护士以及各种其他工作人员打交道。我们要从他们那里得到我们需要的东西，而在这个情境中，他们掌握着所有的权力和知识，他们可能并不像我们自己那样关心我们的护理。罗伯特·利普赛特在他的书《患病之国》中写到了这一点。他说，当他接受化疗时，这意味着要与医院里许多不同的人打交道。
People who check you in, people who weighed you, took your blood pressure, gave you a finger stick because there would have to be a little blood test. And there would be these little interactions with all the people, which always seemed really important. They could hurt you, more or less, depending on the mood. Certainly, they could keep you waiting long or less. And it was almost kind of a ritualistic dance to see how you would really deal with them.
有为你办理入住的人、为你称体重的人、量血压的人、扎你的手指进行验血的人。你会和这些人进行一些小小的互动，这些互动似乎总是非常重要。根据他们的心情，他们可能会多多少少让你受点苦。当然，他们也能让你多等或少等一会儿。看看你如何与他们相处，这简直像是一种仪式化的舞蹈。
Some liked to be joked with, some didn't. Anatole Broyard wrote wonderfully about the need to seduce your doctor, to make medical personnel interested in you.
有些人喜欢开玩笑，有些人则不喜欢。阿纳托尔·布罗亚德曾极好地写到了“诱惑你的医生”的必要性，即让医务人员对你产生兴趣。
In the hospital, we're reduced to the tactics that people have always used throughout human history when they have no power. We yell and scream, hoping that they'll give us what we want, just to shut us up if nothing else. Or we act like supplicants, beggars before the medici, all sweetness and goodwill. Well, today on our program, diplomacy does not just happen at Camp David and in Geneva and at the UN. Some of the most delicate and charged diplomatic negotiations happen every day over matters of life and death at your local neighborhood hospital, as patients try to get what they want, and staff tries to do what they think is best.
在医院里，我们被迫使用人类历史上那些处于弱势地位的人们一直使用的策略。我们大喊大叫，希望能得到我们想要的，哪怕仅仅是为了让他们闭嘴。或者我们表现得像乞求者，在医生面前卑躬屈膝，表现得非常甜美且充满善意。那么，今天在我们的节目中，外交不仅发生在戴维营、日内瓦和联合国。在你们社区医院里，每天都在发生着一些最微妙、最激烈的关于生死的“外交谈判”，患者试图得到他们想要的，而工作人员则试图做他们认为最好的事情。
Act One of our program today, Is That Your Final Answer?, the story of a family in a hospital and why dressing well might get you better medical care.
今天节目的第一幕《这是你的最终答案吗？》，讲述了一个家庭在医院里的故事，以及为什么穿着得体可能会让你得到更好的医疗护理。
Act Two, The Other Nursing Staff, in which reporter Nancy Updike answers this question, do Rosie O'Donnell and Jerry Springer have healing powers?
第二幕《其他护理人员》，记者南希·厄普代克将回答这个问题：罗西·欧唐内和杰瑞·斯普林格有治愈能力吗？
Act Three, Fire and Ice Cream, a 14-year-old boy tries to figure out what it means when his nurse asks him out for dessert.
第三幕《火与冰淇淋》，一名14岁的男孩试图弄明白，当护士约他去吃甜点时，这意味着什么。
Act Four, Looking for Love in all the Wrong Places, the story of what happens when a patient violates one of the most basic rules of what to do in a hospital over and over again, and survives, for a while anyway. Stay with us.
第四幕《在所有错误的地方寻找爱》，讲述了一个病人如何反复违反医院的基本规则，却还是活了下来，至少活了一段时间。请继续收听。
Act One, Is That Your Final Answer? When Terry Shine's father was in hospital, bleeding in his brain, Terry and his four brothers rushed into action. Of course, as anybody who's ever been in this kind of situation knows, action mostly just means sitting around the hospital room trying to figure out what might possibly help things, which is made all the more difficult by the fact that figuring out what might help first requires learning the language and customs of the average American hospital, which Terry Shine's family diligently tried to do.
第一幕《这是你的最终答案吗？》。当特里·沙恩的父亲因脑出血住院时，特里和他的四个兄弟迅速采取了行动。当然，任何有过类似经历的人都知道，行动大多意味着坐在医院房间里，试图想出什么办法能改善情况，而困难在于，要弄清楚什么办法有效，首先需要学习美国普通医院的语言和习俗，特里·沙恩的家人们正努力这样做。
Nothing's changed. He just lies there. Everything's changed. No one goes to work. No one goes to the store. No one makes any plans other than to be at our father's bedside. We've become hospital rats. By day two, we know where the best soda machine is. It has Fresca. By day three, we're no longer using the pay phone, but making free calls from deep inside nursing station B2. By day four, we know who the good nurses are.
什么都没变。他只是躺在那里。一切都变了。没有人去工作。没有人去商店。除了守在父亲床边，没有人做任何计划。我们成了“医院老鼠”。到了第二天，我们已经知道哪里的汽水机最好。它有Fresca汽水。到了第三天，我们不再用投币电话，而是从B2护士站深处拨打免费电话。到了第四天，我们已经知道哪些护士是好护士。
They're so much smarter here in ICU. In the bed, here comes that bitch. By day five, Bill somehow knows what kind of car every doctor drives. The neurosurgeon has an STS Cadillac Seville. The cardiologist, the classic Corvette, The internist, the GMC Yukon. But I think it's his wife's, Bill says. He's got an eye for that kind of thing.
她们在重症监护室（ICU）里聪明多了。躺在床上，那个讨厌的家伙来了。到了第五天，比尔甚至知道每个医生开什么车。神经外科医生开凯迪拉克赛威；心脏科医生开经典克尔维特；内科医生开GMC育空。比尔说，但我认为那是他妻子的车。他在观察这种事上很有一套。
By day six, we know the orderly's hobbies. Gerard flies those radio-controlled airplanes, the big ones. But we know no more about my father's condition. After the surgery, it was all about the swelling going down. The brain has been through two surgeries within a week, the doctor said. Once the swelling goes down, we'll see where we're at. Well, the swelling must have gone down by now, but we don't see a thing.
到了第六天，我们知道了护工的爱好。杰拉德喜欢玩那些无线电遥控飞机，那种大号的。但对于我父亲的病情，我们一无所知。手术后，重点在于消肿。医生说，大脑在一周内经历了两次手术。一旦消肿，我们就能看到情况如何。好吧，肿肯定已经消了，但我们什么也没看到。
Bill has been personalizing the room, bringing in photos and hanging up an article from a Valley Stream, New York newspaper that recently chronicled my father's feats during World War II. There's a photo of 24-year-old Daniel Lawrence Shine in a cool, fur-colored bomber jacket. Bill has marked details in the story with a yellow highlighter.
比尔一直在个性化布置房间，挂上照片，并贴上纽约山谷溪报纸的一篇文章，记录了我父亲在二战期间的壮举。照片上24岁的丹尼尔·劳伦斯·沙恩穿着一件帅气的带毛领飞行员夹克。比尔用黄色荧光笔标出了文章中的细节。
I want the photos by his headboard so the army of medical workers taking blood every hour and constantly needling him for tests can see he's not just a gown and limbs. He's a person who stood next to a Christmas tree two weeks ago in a Pebble Beach golf sweater with grandchildren wrapped around his legs. But my brothers think the pictures should be on the far wall, in his line of sight, so they will be immediately visible when he becomes coherent. They win.
我希望照片贴在床头，这样每小时来抽血、不断对他进行测试的医务大军就能看到，他不只是一个穿着病号服的躯体。他是一个两周前还站在圣诞树旁，穿着圆领毛衣，孙子们绕在腿边的活生生的人。但我的兄弟们认为照片应该挂在远处的墙上，在他视线范围内，这样当他恢复意识时就能立刻看到。他们赢了。
We've had a breakdown in communication with hospital personnel this past week. And I believe I've nailed down the reason. It's fashion. That's what it's come to now. Something tells me that the nurses will start giving us respect. The doctors will start returning our calls. The lady in the gift shop will stop following us to see what we're doing behind that rack of Beanie Babies. All this will happen if we step up our appearance.
过去一周我们与医院人员的沟通陷入了僵局。我相信我已经找到了原因。是时尚。事情就是这样。某种直觉告诉我，如果我们提升一下形象，护士们会开始尊重我们。医生们会开始回复我们的电话。礼品店的那个女人会停止跟踪我们，去看看我们在那个豆豆娃货架后面干什么。只要我们稍微讲究一下穿着，这一切都会发生。
We're a motley crew, and the shorts and Pete's Wicked Ale T-shirts, and Danny always wearing that stupid Fanny pack with his sweat pants are not helping. We've been dressing like emergency room people. The family of citizens who have cut their hands at barbecues or get in freak car accidents on the way home from the beach and have to show up in flip-flops and half-shirts, these poor people are caught with their pants down, but we have no excuse. We have days and days to plan our wardrobe.
我们是一群乌合之众，短裤、印有啤酒广告的T恤，还有丹尼总是穿着运动裤配那个愚蠢的腰包，这些都无济于事。我们的着装就像急诊室的人。那些在烧烤时切伤手或者从海滩回家路上出车祸的市民家庭，不得不穿着人字拖和半截袖出现，这些可怜人被弄得措手不及，但我们没有借口。我们有大把的时间来准备衣物。
We have to start dressing like intensive care people, I tell my wife. I'm certain that the doctors and the nurses will be much more attentive of my father's needs if we only put a little more effort into our appearance. I can hear a nurse now. I know, I just checked on Mr. Shine, but I'm going to check on him again. Those boys of his are so well-groomed
我告诉妻子，我们得开始穿得像重症监护室的人一样。我敢肯定，如果我们稍微多在形象上下点功夫，医生和护士会对父亲的需求更加关注。我仿佛能听到护士说：“我知道我刚看过沙恩先生，但我打算再去看看。他的那些儿子打扮得可真体面。”
So today, I am meticulously laying out my best clothes, running my thumb and forefinger along the sharp creases in my trousers, spray starching my withered collars. Maybe we should get a second opinion, Bill said yesterday, questioning the diagnosis so far. We haven't got a first opinion yet, I told him. Nobody's talking to us anymore. Peter has a million questions about the blood thinner, Coumadin. He's adamant that the doctor should never have prescribed it for my father's heart condition to begin with. From what he's heard, it could have been the cause of the excessive bleeding.
所以今天，我仔细地铺好我最好的衣服，用拇指和食指顺着裤子上挺括的折痕抚平，喷上淀粉浆弄平领子。比尔昨天说，也许我们应该寻求第二意见，质疑目前的诊断。我告诉他，我们连第一意见都还没听到呢。已经没人再和我们说话了。彼得对血液稀释剂“香豆素”有无数疑问。他坚持认为医生一开始就不应该给我父亲的心脏病开这种药。据他所听到的，这可能是导致过度出血的原因。
I looked it up on the computer, and you can't eat salad when you're on it, he says. What kind of medication doesn't allow you to eat salad? Dad loved salad, I say. I want some answers, he says. One doctor up here told me he would never prescribe it for his heart patients. He says something as simple as stopping short in your car can cause bleeding in the brain when you're on that stuff. Someone has to give us some answers.
他说，我在电脑上查过了，服用这种药时不能吃沙拉。什么样的药不让人吃沙拉？我说，爸爸爱吃沙拉。他说，我想要一些答案。这里的一位医生告诉我，他绝不会给他的心脏病人开这种药。他说，服用这种药时，哪怕是开车急刹车这样简单的事，都可能导致脑出血。必须有人给我们一些答案。
But we keep getting passed up and down the chain of command. No one explained the fact that one doctor becomes the primary on the case and coordinates all procedures until after we call half a dozen of the doctors listed on his charts. Not that any of them called us back to tell us that. We had to hear it from a college kid in the snack bar who was recuperating from a street hockey accident. The primary, he said, that's the guy you've got to get to.
但我们一直在指挥链条上被推来推去。没有人解释过为什么会有医生负责统筹所有程序，直到我们给病历单上列出的六七个医生打了电话。并不是说他们回电告诉我们的。我们是从小卖部一个因为玩街头曲棍球受伤正在康复的大学生那里听说的。他说，主治医生，那是你必须找到的人。
Once he put us on the right trail, the nurse told us that we had to talk to our father's cardiologist. But it's his brain that-- He's the primary, she said. But the cardiologist has yet to return our phone calls. Not that we're sitting by the phone anyway. When I get to his room, the nurse tells me the doctor was just in. Which one? I ask. Oh, I haven't seen him before, she says. This is how it works. No matter when you're in the room, the doctor has just been there.
一旦他指对了路，护士告诉我们必须和父亲的心脏科医生谈谈。但我说，是他的大脑……她说，他是主治医生。但心脏科医生至今没有回我们的电话。不过反正我们也没守着电话。当我走进病房时，护士告诉我医生刚来过。我问，哪个？她说，哦，我以前没见过他。事情就是这样。无论你什么时候进病房，医生都刚来过。
We decide the one thing that would probably make us feel better on a day like this would be if we stop respecting doctors. We won't call them doctor anymore. We'll leave off the title and only call them by their last names, I say. They hate that. As the day drags on, we reach a point where not calling doctors doctor doesn't seem extreme enough. We should start calling them by their first name. That'll get 'em, Bill says. But how are we going to find out their first names? Well, Bill says, we'll just call them all Jim.
我们决定，在这样的一天里，能让我们感觉好一点的一件事，就是停止尊重医生。我说，我们不再叫他们“医生”了。去掉这个头衔，只叫他们的姓。他们讨厌这样。随着日子一天天过去，我们觉得光不叫“医生”还不够极致。比尔说，我们应该开始叫他们的名字。那能治住他们。但我们要怎么才能找到他们的名字呢？比尔说，没关系，我们就把他们都叫“吉姆”。
The physician who's been the primary case, the one who's supposed to coordinate all the others and keep the family up to date, finally phones us to tell me he's putting another doctor in charge of my father because, well, I'm not as knowledgeable about the neurological stuff, he says. He schedules a meeting for this evening. You'll meet Dr. Bozeki in the conference room near the ICU, he says. She'll take care of everything from here on out. I wonder what her first name is.
那位一直担任主治医师、理应协调所有其他医生并向家属通报情况的人，终于打电话告诉我，他要换另一位医生来接管我父亲，因为他说：“毕竟，我对神经科的东西了解不多。”他安排了今天晚上的会议。他说：“你们会在ICU附近的会议室见到博泽基医生。从现在起她会处理一切。”我在想她的名字是什么。
The conference room turns out to be the nurses' break room, and they're just getting ready to have a platter of neatly rolled cold cuts and cake for a staffer's birthday. All this for us? Danny says. Dr. Bozeki, who looks like an actress playing a doctor, very ER, can't be more than 27, but she still has the power to get her party moved down the hall with a mere "please move it." She asks us to stand around the garbage can by the phone because my brother Pete in New York is being patched in on the speaker phone.
会议室竟然是护士休息室，她们正准备摆放一盘整齐的冷切肉和蛋糕，为一个员工庆祝生日。丹尼说，这些都是为我们准备的吗？博泽基医生看起来像个演医生的女演员，非常有急诊室风格，顶多27岁，但她仅凭一句“请移开”就有权把她们的聚会挪到走廊那边。她让我们站在电话旁边的垃圾桶周围，因为我们在纽约的弟弟皮特正在通过免提电话连线。
"Hello," Pete says. The doctor starts talking quickly. I don't know your father. I saw some pictures in there. War hero, whatever. But anyway, you have to start thinking about his quality of life from this point on. "Did your father ever talk about death with any of you? Did the subject come up in conversation," she says. Each of the questions is landing with a thud, like mangoes from a tree.
皮特说：“喂。”医生开始快速说话。我不认识你父亲。我看了里面的照片。战争英雄之类的。但不管怎样，你们必须从现在起考虑他的生活质量。她说：“你们父亲有没有和你们谈过死亡？这个话题在谈话中出现过吗？”每一个问题都重重地落下，就像从树上掉下来的芒果。
We are not yet aware that this subject will come up in every conversation we have from this point on, but right now it seems to soon. We were in shock. "You still there, Peter," the doctor asks. Peter's still there. All our days till now have been spend waiting for the swelling to go down so we'll have him back. We know he's still in there. We've seen glimpses of the real him in a squeeze of a hand, a hint of expression, a fleeting moment of eye contact.
我们还不知道从现在起这个话题会在我们每一次谈话中出现，但现在看来太早了。我们处于震惊中。医生问：“皮特，你还在吗？”皮特还在。直到现在，我们所有的日子都在等着肿消下去，这样他就能回到我们身边。我们知道他还在那里。我们在握手中、暗示性的表情里、转瞬即逝的眼神交流中，瞥见了真实的那个他。
The nurses aren't seeing those things, Dr. Bozeki says. A couple of nurses boisterously fling open the door and then go speechless as they gaze upon us all standing around the garbage can talking about death. The party moved, I say. Anyway, the doctor continues, it's time for you to decide this. If your father's heart stops, do we restart it? The consensus of all us doctors is not to. Our consensus is to.
博泽基医生说，护士们并没有看到那些迹象。几个护士吵吵闹闹地推开门，当她们看到我们都站在垃圾桶周围谈论死亡时，瞬间哑口无言。我说，派对挪地方了。无论如何，医生继续说，是时候由你们来做决定了。如果你们父亲的心脏停止跳动，我们要重启它吗？我们医生的共识是不重启。我们的共识是要重启。
The doctor also has one of my father's nurses, a good one, on hand for support. And she asks her to step forward. You shouldn't restart it, the nurse says. She steps backward. We don't know what to say. Up until now, the biggest decision most of us have made in our lives is whether to buy or lease. Our minds are reeling. How much recovery time is a person allowed? I ask. It depends, she answers. Would not restarting his heart include withholding sustenance and water? Bill says.
医生还安排了一位我父亲的护士在场提供支持，她是一位好护士。她请她站出来。护士说，你们不应该重启。然后她退后了。我们不知道该说什么。到目前为止，我们大多数人一生中做过的最大决定就是买车还是租车。我们的头脑一片混乱。我问，一个人被允许有多少恢复时间？她回答说，这取决于情况。比尔说，不重启心脏是否包括拒绝提供维持生命的营养和水？
Has your father talked to you about this? Bozeki asks pointedly. Bill says yeah but doesn't give her any more detail. He wants to know more about how much progress they actually think my father could make. Would he be able to watch TV? Yes. There's more to life than watching TV, the doctor says. We all look at one another. It is times like this when I know my brothers and I are truly related. God, I wish I had a sister.
博泽基尖锐地问，你们父亲和你们谈过这方面的事吗？比尔说谈过，但没有提供更多细节。他想了解更多关于他们认为父亲实际上能恢复到什么程度。医生说，他能看电视吗？能。医生说，生活不仅仅是看电视。我们面面相觑。每当这个时候，我就知道我和我的兄弟们确实是亲人。天哪，我真希望有个姐妹。
So you're saying he'll be able to watch TV, Danny says. The doctor sees she's getting nowhere, tells us to sleep on it and quickly exits, probably in a hurry to get to the party. Peter, are you still there? the nurse asks. Peter's still there. OK, we're going to hang up on you now, the nurse says. OK, Peter says.
丹尼说，所以你是说他能看电视了？医生看出她在我们这里占不到便宜，告诉我们要慎重考虑，然后迅速离开，大概是急着去聚会了。护士问：“皮特，你还在吗？”皮特还在。护士说，好的，我们要挂断你的电话了。皮特说，好的。
His legs are kicking and his arms are flailing, and this is no seizure. After the doomsday talk from Bozeki, while the rest of us were whining, Bill has spent hours with Dad, barking directly into his ear, telling him he had to put on a show or the doctors were going to give up on him. And something must have clicked, because today he's dancing. We brought in some of his CDs. Louis and Ella are on the boombox, and his toe is tapping.
他的腿在踢，手臂在挥舞，这不是癫痫发作。在博泽基那种世界末日般的谈话之后，当我们在抱怨的时候，比尔花了几个小时和爸爸待在一起，对着他的耳朵大喊，告诉他必须表现一下，否则医生就会放弃他。有些事情一定被触动了，因为今天他在跳舞。我们带了一些他的CD来。路易斯·阿姆斯特朗和埃拉·费兹杰拉德的音乐在音箱里播放，他的脚趾在打拍子。
[MUSIC - "A FINE ROMANCE" BY ELLA FITZGERALD AND LOUIS ARMSTRONG]
[音乐 - “一场美好的浪漫”，埃拉·费兹杰拉德与路易斯·阿姆斯特朗合唱]
We are impressed, but the nurses aren't. They look at us like, yeah, that's OK if you want someone who's just going to tap his toe for the rest of his life. They want to see more than instinctive movement and the following of commands. They want to see communication. Dad, can you respond to a question by holding up one finger for yes and two for no? Bill says. Nothing. But we keep working, trying different things. I tickle his feet, but Danny scolds me. You don't tickle a man's feet when he's in this condition. New family rule. We're to do everything in our power to bring him back around, but we draw the line at tickling.
我们印象深刻，但护士们不为所动。她们看我们的眼神仿佛在说，好吧，如果你们想要一个余生只会动动脚趾的人，那没问题。她们想看到的不仅仅是本能的动作和对指令的跟随。她们想看到交流。比尔说，爸爸，你能通过竖起一根手指表示“是”，两根手指表示“否”来回应问题吗？没有反应。但我们继续努力，尝试各种方法。我挠他的脚底，丹尼斥责我。当他这种状况时，你不能挠他的脚底。这是新的家庭规则。我们要尽一切努力让他恢复，但在挠脚底这件事上我们要划清界限。
Our brother, Pete, bursts into the room. There's no door to swing open or even a curtain to throw aside, but he always oozes adrenalin and his stocky Beretta build pushes you aside. He's come directly from the airport and he's desperately charged up. Dad, it's me, Pete. Nod if you can hear me. He nods. We jump in the air. How could we not think of the nod? How come you didn't think of the nod? I punch Danny. Why do we have to fly a guy in from New York to come up with the nod? Shouldn't the doctors have thought of the nod? Danny says.
我们的兄弟皮特冲进房间。这里没有门可以推开，甚至没有帘子可以拉开，但他总是充满肾上腺素，他那结实的体格把人都推到了一边。他直接从机场赶来，情绪极其亢奋。皮特说，爸爸，是我，皮特。如果你能听见就点头。他点头了。我们跳了起来。我们怎么就没想到点头？丹尼说，你怎么就没想到点头？我给了丹尼一拳。为什么要从纽约飞个人过来才想出点头？医生难道不应该想到点头吗？
Believe me, we're not high-five people, but we're high-fiving. For me, it's a first. You're not good at it, Danny says. I've got a copy of the living will in my pocket, but there's no need for it now. If they want to know if he wants his heart restarted, they can ask him. We've got his attention. If anyone can pull through this, you can, Dad, Bill says. We run into the hallway and drag a nurse in. Ask him a question, Peter demands. She asks, he nods yes. He shakes no.
相信我，我们不是那种爱击掌的人，但我们在击掌。对我来说，这是第一次。丹尼说，你一点都不擅长。我口袋里有生前预嘱的复印件，但现在不需要了。如果他们想知道他是否希望重启心脏，他们可以问他。我们吸引了他的注意力。比尔说，爸爸，如果有人能挺过这一关，那一定是你。我们跑到走廊，把一个护士拉了进来。皮特要求道，问他一个问题。她问了，他点头表示“是”。他摇头表示“不”。
So what are you going to tell the doctors if they ask you if he's able to communicate? Peter corners her. What are you going to say? She nods yes. Yes, victory. We have communication. We have confirmation. We have progress. We're progress in motion. We've got all four corners of his bed covered. We don't know how long this window of coherency is going to last, so we're frantically asking yes and no questions and manipulating his arms and legs.
皮特堵住她说，那么如果医生问你他是否能交流，你会怎么告诉他们？你会说什么？她点头表示“是”。是的，胜利。我们有交流了。我们有确认了。我们有进展了。我们是进展中的。我们覆盖了他床位的全部四个角落。我们不知道这种清醒的窗口期会持续多久，所以我们疯狂地问着是非题，并摆弄着他的手臂和腿。
He's shuffling his legs around like he's restless and he wants to get up and walk. I take my hands and apply pressure to the soles of his feet, and he starts pumping his legs. His knees are up and he's wildly peddling against my hands. Yeah, this is OK, if you want someone who's just going to ride a bike around for the rest of his life, I howl. I ask him for the thumbs up, he delivers. Applause breaks out.
他像坐立难安一样移动着双腿，好像他想起来走路。我用双手压住他的脚底，他开始用力蹬腿。他的膝盖抬起来，对着我的手狂乱地踩踏着自行车。我大喊道，好吧，如果你们想要一个余生只能骑自行车的人，那没问题。我让他竖个大拇指，他做到了。掌声四起。
The nurse catches the erect thumb out of the corner of her eye and gives us a sort of pitiful grin. Yeah, that's OK, if you want someone who's just going to give you the thumbs up for the rest of his life. She's the rain pouring through our open window, but we're not going to let her bring it all down. Our blue eyes are clear. I love you, Dad, Pete says. I can't believe we didn't think of the nod, Danny says.
护士用眼角余光看到了那个竖起的大拇指，给了我们一个怜悯的微笑。是的，如果你们想要一个余生只会竖大拇指的人，那没问题。她是穿透我们打开的窗户的雨水，但我们不会让她把一切都浇灭。我们的蓝眼睛很清澈。皮特说，爸爸，我爱你。丹尼说，真不敢相信我们竟然没想到点头。
We're coming from opposite ends of the hospital parking lot. We've got newspapers tucked under our arms. We both have big plans today. I'm going to turn that corner of the hospital room and Dad's going to be feeling good enough to sit up, and I'm going to read him current events. The prime is down and John Glenn's going up. Bill has bigger plans. I brought his reading glasses, he says, so he can read the paper himself.
我们从医院停车场的两端走过来。我们腋下夹着报纸。我们今天都有大计划。我打算绕过病房的那个角落，希望爸爸感觉好到能坐起来，我会读新闻给他听。总理下台了，约翰·格伦准备升空。比尔有更大的计划。他说，我带了他的老花镜，这样他可以自己看报纸。
We're only a couple of days away from the thumbs up, but he's a million miles away. There'll be no reaching him today. For the first time, I not only feel sorry for my father, but I feel sorry for us. We are standing on opposite sides of the bed, our papers in hand, and we do look pitiful. It's just what the nurses had been saying. My father lying there motionless, us incessantly, relentlessly trying to get a rise, a trick out of him like he's a show pony. Maybe all he needs is some peace.
我们距离竖大拇指才过去几天，但他已经远在天边。今天无论如何也联系不上他了。这是第一次，我不仅为我的父亲感到难过，也为我们自己感到难过。我们站在病床的两侧，手里拿着报纸，看起来确实很可怜。这正是护士们所说的。我父亲无动于衷地躺在那里，而我们不断地、无情地试图从他身上得到一种反应，像对待杂耍小马一样诱骗他。也许他所需要的只是宁静。
I wonder if our one great day with Louis and Ella wasn't quite the glorious lift toward the plateau we'd been hoping for, but more of a gift, a chance for us to openly profess our love and for him to give us the nod of acceptance. You know, when he was responding with hand signals and whatnot, I had asked Bozeki if we could hold up the living will and ask him for a yes or no. She said, absolutely not.
我想知道我们与路易斯和埃拉相处的那美好的一天，是否并没有达到我们所希望的那个平台，而更像是一份礼物，一个让我们公开表达爱意，让他给我们认可的点头的机会。你知道，当他用手势回应时，我曾问过博泽基，我们是否可以举起生前预嘱问他要“是”或“否”。她说，绝对不行。
I scoffed at her at the time, but I realize now how any man at this point, lying there clamped down like a trapped animal with burning medicine chasing the pain through his veins, any man in that condition is going to want desperately to fight to the end. Just as they say the soul is the last thing to leave the body, mental confidence must be the first thing to flee in a situation such as this, not only for him, but for all of us, I'm afraid.
我当时嘲笑她，但我现在意识到，任何处于这种状态的人，像被困的动物一样被固定在那里，灼热的药物在他血管里追逐着痛苦，任何处于这种状况的人，都会极其渴望战斗到底。正如人们所说，灵魂是最后离开身体的东西，在这样的情况下，精神的自信一定是第一个逃跑的，不仅是他，恐怕对我们所有人来说也是如此。
We're like a crazed animal. At this point, the only thing his body has left to offer is instinct and insanity. And it's become so hard to trust our judgment, because I wonder if we are not on the same course.
我们就像疯掉的动物。此时此刻，他的身体唯一能提供的是本能和疯狂。这让我很难相信我们的判断，因为我在怀疑，我们是否在重蹈覆辙。
The pulmonary doctor, a young guy who looks sort of like a QVC fitness guru, charges in and gives us a little pep talk, tells us to keep it up. Don't worry about what the nurses think. He responds to you guys. You've got to keep working it, he says. He's fiddling with the end of his stethoscope, as if any second he's going to put it to his lips, blow it like a whistle, and my father's going to shoot out of the starting blocks.
肺科医生，一个看起来像电视购物健身教练的年轻人，冲进来给我们打气，告诉我们要坚持下去。别管护士怎么想。他说，他会对你们做出反应。你们必须继续努力。他摆弄着听诊器末端，仿佛下一秒他就要把它放到唇边，像吹哨子一样吹响，我父亲就会从起跑线上冲出去。
Before you know it, he'll be ready for aggressive rehab, he says. Just keep it up, up, up. You're making a difference. As soon as he leaves the room, Bill says, Mitsubishi 3000GT, black. I mentioned to one of the nurses that we really like that doctor. And she explains to me in her own convoluted way that the personable doctors are the bad doctors. And the ones with no personality are the ones you'd actually want operating on you. Well, in that case, I think we've got some of the best in the business.
他说，很快他就能进行积极的康复治疗了。只要继续坚持下去。你们正在产生影响。他刚离开房间，比尔就说，三菱3000GT，黑色的。我向一位护士提到我们真的很喜欢那位医生。她用她那令人困惑的方式向我解释说，亲切的医生是坏医生。而那些没有个性的医生才是你真正希望为你做手术的人。好吧，如果是那样，我想我们拥有业内最好的。
Terry Shine. This is an excerpt from his book, Fathers Aren't Supposed to Die.
特里·沙恩。这是他书中的节选，《父亲不应该死去》。
[MUSIC - "TOMMY GETS HIS TONSILS OUT" BY THE REPLACEMENTS]
[音乐 - “汤米切除了扁桃体”，The Replacements乐队]
Act Two, The Other Nursing Staff. It seemed to us that no radio program about caregivers in a hospital could be complete without a few words about the caregiver that is the most omnipresent, in every room, 24/7, in the waiting rooms, at the nurses station a lot of times. I'm talking, of course, about television. To investigate its power in a medical facility, reporter Nancy Updike went to the most television-friendly hospital imaginable, the one that actual television stars go to when they get sick, Cedar Sinai in Los Angeles.
第二幕《其他护理人员》。在我们看来，任何关于医院护理人员的广播节目，如果不提一提那个最无处不在的照顾者，那都是不完整的。它在每个房间，24小时不间断；它在候诊室里，在护士站里。我指的当然是电视。为了调查其在医疗机构中的力量，记者南希·厄普代克去了最能体现电视价值的医院，即真正的电视明星生病时会去的医院——洛杉矶的锡达赛奈医疗中心。
After staying at Cedar Sinai and seeing the quality of what was on the tube there, Milton Berle and Johnny Carson both donated old shows of theirs to broadcast in-house. Here's Nancy's report.
在锡达赛奈住过并看过那里的电视节目质量后，米尔顿·伯尔和约翰尼·卡森都捐赠了他们旧时的节目在内部广播。这是南希的报道。
This is how a lot of people feel about watching television in the hospital.
这就是很多人在医院看电视时的感受。
I should be a much better person and I should've tried to improve my mind while I'm here, but I just don't have the patience for it. So I slip into the degradation of this crap television.
我应该成为一个更好的人，我应该在我在这里的时候试着提升自己的修养，但我实在没有耐心。所以我滑入了这些垃圾电视的颓废中。
I would like to think that I'm the kind of person that could just turn it off and that it wouldn't affect me.
我愿意认为我是一个能够把它关掉，并且它不会影响到我的人。
Do you know this is what alcoholics say?
你知道这是酗酒者常说的话吗？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Oh, I could quit any time.
哦，我可以随时戒掉。
But when I think about it, if I couldn't watch TV, I'm not, you know-- I don't know, I think that maybe I would go a little nuts.
但仔细想想，如果我不能看电视，我不知道……我觉得我可能会有点疯掉。
These are two of the patients I talked to at Cedar Sinai. The guy is Jay Mason, a 74-year-old with a nasty scar running from just under his adam's apple all the way down his chest. He's had a lot of heart surgery. The woman is LeShaun Smith, who's been lying in the same uncomfortable position for almost a month. She's 31 and having her first baby, and she has to stay in bed with her whole body angled head downwards so that her water doesn't break too soon. She'll stay in that position until the baby's born. She has three months to go.
这是我在锡达赛奈谈话的两位病人。那个男的是杰伊·梅森，74岁，喉结下方到胸口有一道可怕的疤痕。他做过很多心脏手术。那位女士是勒肖恩·史密斯，她已经在同一个不舒服的姿势下躺了近一个月了。她31岁，怀着第一个孩子，她必须整个身体斜着头朝下躺着，以免羊水过早破裂。她要保持那个姿势直到孩子出生。她还要再等三个月。
And to begin our discussion, let's start here, in this very hospital. So OK, even if you've never actually been a patient in a hospital, you kind of already know what it's like, right?
作为讨论的开始，让我们从这里，从这家医院开始吧。那么好吧，即使你从来没有住过院，你也大概知道那是什么样子，对吧？
There is no such thing as privacy.
根本没有隐私可言。
You know, people going in and out of your room, looking at you and peeking at you, wondering what's wrong with you.
你知道，人们进进出出你的房间，看着你，偷窥你，想知道你得了什么病。
Taking your temperature, taking blood.
量体温，抽血。
They wake me up early to do vital signs and stuff, and I try to go back to sleep. I mean, we're talking, like, 5:30.
他们大清早把我就醒来测量生命体征之类的，我试着继续睡。我是说，那可是早上5点半。
The day goes very, very, very laboriously.
这一天过得非常、非常、非常费劲。
You know, having people to have to do everything for you, and not being able to do things for yourself.
你知道，让人们不得不为你做所有事情，而自己却无法做任何事。
You know, you live for the day you get outta here.
你知道，你活着就是为了离开这里的那一天。
So let's summarize. You're sick, you're lonely, but also completely without privacy. You're exhausted, helpless, and you are so, so, so bored. The culture of the hospital is divided into one group of people that is rushing around from the moment they walk in the door in the morning until the second they leave at night, and another group that is just languishing, numb. And you and I are probably going to be in that second group, right?
让我们总结一下。你生病了，你很孤独，而且完全没有隐私。你筋疲力尽，无助，而且你感到非常、非常、非常无聊。医院文化分为两类人，一类人从早上踏进门的那一刻起一直到晚上离开，都在忙碌奔走；另一类人则只是虚弱无力、麻木地躺着。你和我大概都会属于第二类人，对吧？
So we comfort ourselves. And we're not too choosy about how.
所以我们要自我安慰。而我们对用什么方式并不挑剔。
7:00 in the morning, watch the news. Then I watch Sally Jesse.
早上7点，看新闻。然后我看萨莉·杰西。
One night stands become booty-calls, next Ricky.
一夜情变成了炮友，接下来是瑞奇。
I just watch crap here. And like anything, a cooking show, a--
我在这里只看垃圾节目。像任何东西，烹饪节目，一个……
Steve Harvey, Moesha, The Parkers, Malcolm & Eddie. I love seeing black people on televisions. Channel 2, Young and the Restless. And then Channel 7, All My Children. Then Channel 4, Days of Our Lives.
史蒂夫·哈维，《莫伊莎》，《派克一家》，《马尔科姆与艾迪》。我喜欢在电视上看到黑人。2频道，《年轻气盛》。然后7频道，《我的孩子们》。然后4频道，《我们的日子》。
So you're just as bad as Sasha here. you slept with your best friend's man.
那你和这儿的萨沙一样糟糕，你睡了你最好的朋友的男人。
It's almost as provocative in America to say that television has therapeutic value as it is to say that smoking pot does. We associate both with wayward teenagers, wasting their lives and rotting their brains, engaging in insidious activities like hanging out and chilling. But TV is so important to the patients at Cedar Sinai that the woman who runs the video department there has been paged at home, on weekends and at night, by irate patients complaining about missing a ballgame or a movie because of some technical problem or programming change.
在美国，说电视有治疗价值，几乎就像说抽大麻一样具有争议性。我们把两者都与误入歧途的青少年联系在一起，认为他们在浪费生命、腐烂大脑，沉溺于闲逛和放松等隐蔽活动。但电视对锡达赛奈的病人非常重要，以至于那里的视频部门负责人曾在周末和晚上被愤怒的病人叫醒，抱怨因为技术故障或节目调整错过了一场球赛或一部电影。
One patient I talked to had even been so desperate to amuse herself that she hunkered down one day and became the world's leading expert on--
我谈过的一个病人甚至为了娱乐自己走投无路，有一天她埋头苦干，成了世界上领先的……
Weekend at Bernie's . I think I must have saw it, like, four times on Saturday, because I couldn't find anything else on there that I wanted to watch.
《老板度假去》的专家。我想我在周六那天一定看了四遍，因为我找不到其他任何我想看的东西。
Talk about making lemonade from lemons. What is this except the mind tenderly saying to the body, listen, don't you worry about me for a while, I'll take care of myself, you just focus on getting better? This is the life-changing lesson hospitals have to offer-- TV is good for you.
把柠檬变成柠檬水。除了思想温柔地对身体说：“听着，你别担心我，我会照顾好自己，你只管专注恢复”，这还有什么？这就是医院必须提供的改变人生的课程——电视对你有益。
This is unbelievable. Can you imagine people before used to lay in hospital beds for days and weeks on end, and just stared at this wall, and sometimes turned their head sideways and looked at that wall? That's horrendous. But my god, you've got to-- you know, you can turn loose a little bit of fantasy. And if it's junk, what the hell's the difference? It's junk, so who cares? At least it's killing time.
这太不可思议了。你能想象以前的人在医院病床上躺上几天几周，只是盯着这面墙，有时转头看着那面墙吗？那太可怕了。但天哪，你必须……你知道，你可以稍微释放一下幻想。如果那是垃圾，那又有什么区别？那是垃圾，所以谁在乎呢？至少它在打发时间。
I guess I'm sort of arguing that, in that sense, it's not junk.
我想我在争辩说，从那个意义上讲，它不是垃圾。
Well, I think that you're right. In that sense, it is not junk. It fills my lonely hours and kind of gets me through the day. And that's a good thing.
好吧，我认为你说得对。从那个意义上讲，它不是垃圾。它填补了我孤独的时间，并帮助我度过这一天。那是一件好事。
Outside the hospital, people call TV crap, because it's an anesthetic. Watching hours and hours of TV makes us feel spoiled, self-indulgent, numb. But so what? I mean, think about it. Novocaine and morphine make you feel numb, too, and no one's calling them crap.
在医院外面，人们称电视为垃圾，因为它是一种麻醉剂。看几个小时的电视会让我们感到被宠坏了，自我放纵，麻木。但这又怎样？我是说，仔细想想。诺卡因和吗啡也会让你感到麻木，也没有人称它们为垃圾。
Nancy Updike in Los Angeles. Coming up, an argument that Medicare payments should cover trips to pick up Ben and Jerry's, and somebody who actually liked staying in the hospital, liked it so much that it got her in trouble. That's all in a minute, from Public Radio International, when our program continues.
洛杉矶的南希·厄普代克。接下来，关于医疗保险应该覆盖买冰淇淋的费用的争论，以及一个真正喜欢待在医院里的人，她喜欢到甚至给自己惹了麻烦。这一切都在一分钟后，来自国际公共广播电台（PRI），节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, Hospital Diplomacy, stories of the delicate and sometimes less-than-delicate interaction of patients and hospital staff in a setting where lives are at stake. We have arrived at Act Three of our show. Act Three, Fire and Ice Cream.
这里是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，我们当然会选择一个主题，带给你们各种关于该主题的故事。今天的节目《医院外交》，讲述了在生死攸关的环境中，病人和医务人员之间微妙甚至不那么微妙的互动。我们来到了节目的第三幕。第三幕《火与冰淇淋》。
This is a story about how patients and medical staff actually can get along just fine, but how when that happens, it can still leave everybody involved scratching their heads with unanswered questions. About a decade ago, when Brent Runyon was 14, he was burned badly enough that he ended up in Children's National Medical Center's burn unit in Washington, DC. Burns covered 85% of his body. He put together this story about it with the help of radio producer, Jay Allison.
这是一个关于病人和医务人员如何能够相处得很好，但当这种情况发生时，依然会让所有相关人员挠头，留下未解之谜的故事。大约十年前，当布伦特·鲁尼恩14岁时，他被严重烧伤，最终住进了华盛顿特区国家儿童医疗中心的烧伤病房。烧伤面积覆盖了他85%的身体。在广播制作人杰·艾利森的帮助下，他整理了这个故事。
During the first weeks in the burn unit, pain blurred from my ones like airhorns at a high school football game. I hated my body, my nerves, my brain. I wanted them all to just shut up. There were only a few times I wasn't in pain. Once before burn therapy, Tina, my nurse, pushed morphine straight into my bloodstream instead of dripping it through the IV. I asked her to push it. I begged her to let me feel it all at once, to blow out my mind like an overexposed photograph, and she did.
在烧伤病房的前几周，痛苦模糊地像高中橄榄球比赛中的号角声。我讨厌我的身体、我的神经、我的大脑。我想让它们都闭嘴。我只有几次不觉得痛。有一次在烧伤治疗前，我的护士蒂娜把吗啡直接打进我的血流中，而不是通过静脉滴注。我让她快点注射。我乞求她让我一次感觉到它，像曝光过度的照片一样炸开我的思维，她照做了。
For 30 seconds, I couldn't feel my body. My vision was whitewashed, and I understood why someone would want to be an addict. When I could talk again, I mumbled, why don't they sell this stuff on the streets? They could make a fortune. Tina unwrapped my bandages, exposing my legs to the air. I looked down. They didn't look like legs at all. They were skinny and useless, so many shades of purple they didn't even look real.
有30秒，我感觉不到我的身体。我的视野一片惨白，我明白了为什么有人想成为瘾君子。当我能再次说话时，我咕哝着，为什么他们不在街上卖这东西？他们可以发大财。蒂娜拆掉我的绷带，让我的双腿暴露在空气中。我低头看去。它们看起来根本不像腿。它们瘦弱而无用，紫色的色调多到甚至看起来不像真的。
I saw the massive wound, as big as a mailbox on my left thigh, where the fire had burned all the way through to the muscle. Tina saw me looking, leaned over and whispered what she always said, it's OK. It's going to get better. The redness means that it's healing.
我看到了左大腿上那个像信箱一样大的伤口，火已经烧到了肌肉。蒂娜看到我在看，俯身悄悄说了她总是说的那句话：“没关系。会好起来的。红色意味着正在愈合。”
I closed my eyes and braced myself for what was coming next. She would begin by cleaning each open wound on my feet, working up to my thighs, and then she would turn me on my stomach to clean the holes on my back. The pain roared from my legs as she cleaned the first wound. Tina explained that my body was healing, and that healing was one of the most painful things a body could do. She said that pain meant I was getting better.
我闭上眼睛，为接下来的事情做准备。她会从清洁我脚上的每一个开放性伤口开始，向上一直到大腿，然后她会让我翻身趴着，清洁我背上的洞。当她清理第一个伤口时，痛苦从我的腿部咆哮而出。蒂娜解释说我的身体正在愈合，而愈合是身体能做的最痛苦的事情之一。她说痛苦意味着我正在好转。
It didn't feel like I was getting better. My skin was tissue paper, and she was tearing at it with steel wool. She told me that if it hurt too much, that I should scream as loud as I could. And at first, I didn't want to. I thought it would be rude or disruptive, and that I could just close my mind to the pain if I tried. But she said that I should scream, and that would let some of the pain out.
感觉并不像是我正在好转。我的皮肤像纸巾，而她用钢丝棉在撕扯它。她告诉我如果太痛，就应该尽可能大声地尖叫。起初，我不想这样做。我觉得那太无礼或太吵闹了，如果我努力，我可以把思维从痛苦中关掉。但她说我应该尖叫，那样可以释放一些痛苦。
And so she cleaned every wound three times, I screamed, and it became a kind of Waltz, with Tina counting her swipes aloud, and me screaming, 1, 2, 3, scream. 1, 2, 3, scream. After she covered me in gauze and Ace bandages, my body was shivering. I was exhausted, crying a little bit, trying not to think about how I'd have to do it all over again in eight hours.
于是她三次清洁了每一个伤口，我尖叫，这成了一种华尔兹，蒂娜大声数着她的擦拭次数，我尖叫着：1、2、3，尖叫。1、2、3，尖叫。当她给我盖上纱布和绷带后，我的身体在发抖。我筋疲力尽，哭了一点点，试图不去想八小时后还要再经历一遍。
Tina stood at the head of my bed, her thick black curls spiraled toward my face. Brent, she said, do you like ice cream? It seemed like a silly question, since I was still getting fed through a tube in my nose. When you get that nose tube out, when you can walk again, I'm going to take you to the best ice cream shop in DC. It had been weeks since I'd eaten anything, and I hadn't even thought about ice cream. I couldn't believe it. Tina and I would go out for ice cream when I could walk. We would go on a date.
蒂娜站在我的床头，她浓密的黑色卷发盘在我的脸庞。她说：“布伦特，你喜欢冰淇淋吗？”这似乎是个愚蠢的问题，因为我当时还是通过鼻饲管进食。她说：“等你拔掉鼻饲管，当你能再次行走时，我会带你去特区最好的冰淇淋店。”我已经几周没吃过东西了，甚至没想过冰淇淋。我不敢相信。等我能走的时候，蒂娜和我会去吃冰淇淋。我们要去约会了。
It was eight weeks later, and it was going to be my first time outside the burn unit. Most of the pain had gone and been replaced by the itch. Anyone who's ever had a burn can tell you that the itch comes after the pain, and that it's sometimes worse because it's constant. It made me feel like the skin on my body didn't belong to me, as if it had been stripped away in my sleep and replaced with raw wool.
八周后，这将是我第一次离开烧伤病房。大部分痛苦已经消失，取而代之的是瘙痒。任何烧伤过的人都会告诉你，瘙痒出现在痛苦之后，而且有时更糟，因为它是持续不断的。它让我觉得身体上的皮肤不属于我，仿佛它在睡梦中被剥掉，换成了生羊毛。
I prepared for hours for my date with Tina. My mom and another nurse named Barbara picked out the loosest, least-irritating clothing, and they helped me into a pair of baggy athletic pants and a Hard Rock Cafe London T-shirt that my mom said looked really cool. They discussed whether I should wear the pressure bandage that masked part of my face. And then Barbara slipped the chin strap over my head and Velcroed it behind my neck. She put a purple Los Angeles Lakers cap on me to cover part of the bandage. They both said that I looked handsome. I didn't look in a mirror.
我为与蒂娜的约会准备了几个小时。我妈妈和另一位名叫芭芭拉的护士挑选了最宽松、最不刺激的衣服，她们帮我穿上一条宽松的运动裤和一件我妈妈说看起来很酷的Hard Rock Cafe伦敦T恤。她们讨论我是否应该戴上遮住部分脸部的压力绷带。然后芭芭拉把下巴带套在我的头上，在脖子后面粘好魔术贴。她给我戴上一顶紫色的洛杉矶湖人队帽子来遮盖绷带的一部分。她们都说我看起来很帅。我没有照镜子。
Finally, Tina came to pick me up for our date. She had taken off her scrubs and put on a loose white sweater. Her functional shoes were replaced with green All Stars, and she was wearing shorts. I'd never seen her in shorts before. She looked so relaxed, not like a nurse at all. She smiled at me from the doorway. As a burn nurse in a children's hospital, Tina rarely had patients that she could talk to. Most of the kids she took care of were two-year-olds, kids that could walk well enough to pull boiling water down from the stove, but couldn't understand that it wasn't her fault that they were in pain.
终于，蒂娜来接我约会了。她脱下了刷手服，换上了一件宽松的白色毛衣。她那实用的工作鞋换成了绿色的全明星帆布鞋，她穿着短裤。我以前从未见过她穿短裤。她看起来很放松，一点也不像个护士。她在门口对我笑了笑。作为儿童医院的烧伤科护士，蒂娜很少有能谈得来的病人。她照顾的大多数孩子都是两岁大的幼儿，他们走得足够好，能把锅里的开水拉下来，却无法理解并不是她的错让他们处于痛苦中。
Those kids hated her for hurting them. They panicked every time she came near them. But I knew that the pain wasn't her fault. I talked to her, and we made each other laugh. Could a 26-year-old burn nurse be interested in her 14-year-old patient? I was in love with Tina, and I was sure that she was at least a little bit in love with me, too. Why else would she take me out on a date? And she had called it a date. Why else would she wear shorts, or green shoes, a clear sign to a 14-year-old boy that says, go, go, go?
那些孩子恨她伤害他们。每次她走近，他们就会惊慌失措。但我知道痛苦不是她的错。我和她交谈，我们逗得对方大笑。一个26岁的烧伤科护士会对她14岁的病人感兴趣吗？我爱上了蒂娜，而且我确定她至少也有一点点爱我。否则她为什么要带我出去约会？而且她确实把它称作“约会”。否则她为什么要穿短裤，或者绿色的鞋子，这对一个14岁的男孩来说是一个明确的信号：去吧，去吧，去吧？
We waited for the elevator next to a hospital directory sign, and I decided to make my first joke. I cleared my throat and said, spina bifida, that sounds like some sort of Greek food. Tina made a face and said, you wouldn't say that if you knew what it was. The elevator doors opened. Walking out of the hospital with Tina made me feel like I was on a real date, although I had never been on a date before. Something about being on my own feet, walking into the fresh air, the afternoon sunlight, a woman next to me, a woman who had, I reminded myself, already seen me naked.
我们在医院目录牌旁等电梯，我决定开我的第一个玩笑。我清了清嗓子说：“脊柱裂，那听起来像某种希腊食物。”蒂娜做了个鬼脸说：“如果你知道那是什么，你就不会这么说了。”电梯门开了。和蒂娜走出医院让我觉得真的在约会，尽管我以前从未约会过。某种关于用自己的脚站立、走进新鲜空气、下午的阳光、身边的女人，一个已经——我提醒自己——已经看过我赤身裸体的女人。
But by the time we got the car, I was exhausted. Sweating from the few remaining pores in my forehead and armpits, the itch which had been mercifully quiet during the first few minutes of our date started buzzing in my legs. Tina must have noticed that I was uncomfortable, because she put the back of her hand-- no rubber glove, her actual hand-- against my forehead, and wiped the beading sweat away. What did that mean? I wondered to myself.
但当我们到达车前时，我已经筋疲力尽。额头和腋下仅存的几个毛孔冒着汗，在约会最初几分钟里幸好安静下来的瘙痒开始在我的腿上嗡嗡作响。蒂娜一定注意到我不舒服，因为她把手背——没有戴橡胶手套，她真实的手——贴在我的额头上，抹去了汗水。我心里纳闷，那意味着什么？
Tina parked about a block away from the ice cream place she'd been telling me about, got out of the car and rushed around to my side to open the door. That's sweet, I thought. I wish I had done that for her. She helped me on to my feet, and we began walking towards the ice cream place. You OK? she asked. Sure, I said. You?
蒂娜在离她提到的冰淇淋店大约一个街区的地方停车，下车冲到我这边为我打开车门。我想，真贴心。希望我能为她做那件事。她帮我站稳，我们开始走向冰淇淋店。她问：“你还好吗？”我说：“当然。你呢？”
I was trying to ignore the itch that had spread up my legs and into my back. I was walking. That was the important thing. And I was on a date. Inside, the cool air dried the sweat on my forehead, and I began to feel more confident. I let out a sigh of relief just to let her know that the worst was over, and that we would start to have fun any second. We stood in line behind a few senior citizens that were deciding between pistachio and butter pecan.
我试图忽略那已经蔓延到我的腿和背部的瘙痒。我在走路。那才是重要的。而且我正在约会。店里凉爽的空气吹干了我额头上的汗水，我开始感到更自信了。我如释重负地叹了口气，只是为了让她知道最坏的情况已经过去，我们随时都可以开始玩得开心。我们站在几个正在纠结开心果还是奶油碧根果的老年人后面。
I smiled at her and rolled my eyes a little as if to say, can you believe these old people? They're so slow. And she smiled back. This is working, I thought. This is really working. It was then that I saw the ice cream guy checking Tina out from behind the counter. He was college-aged, handsome. I knew what he was thinking.
我对她笑了笑，白眼翻了一下，仿佛在说：“你能相信这些老家伙吗？他们太慢了。”她也回了我一个微笑。我想，这行得通。这真的行得通。就在那时，我看到那个卖冰淇淋的家伙在柜台后面盯着蒂娜看。他大约大学生年纪，很帅。我知道他在想什么。
We stepped up to the counter and I prepared myself for the flirting. And then he looked at me, and a smile dropped into an expression of mock pain as he said, ouch, what happened to you? As soon as he said it, I felt the blood pool in my legs and the itch throb all over my body. I backed up a little, stepped away from the counter. I looked down at my feet. I put my hands in my pockets. I didn't want to talk to him anymore. I didn't want to say anything.
我们走到柜台前，我准备好接受调情。然后他看着我，笑容落入一种伪装的痛苦表情，他说：“哎哟，你怎么了？”就在他说这句话的时候，我感觉到血液在腿部汇集，瘙痒在全身搏动。我往后退了一点，远离柜台。我低头看着脚。我把手放进兜里。我不想再和他说话了。我不想说任何话。
Tina finally broke the spell and asked me what kind of ice cream I wanted. It was all I could do to mumble, chocolate. My head still cast downward, studying the tile patterns, I asked her if we could eat it in the car on the way back to the hospital. And she said that we could. On the way home, I reached up and touched the long purple scar on my cheek. I pinched the edge and blanched it white between my fingers. The scar was numb on my cheek, lifeless and hard, like a wad of gum under a school desk.
蒂娜终于打破了僵局，问我想吃什么口味的冰淇淋。我费了很大劲才咕哝道：“巧克力。”我的头依然垂着，研究着瓷砖图案，我问她我们能不能在回医院的车上吃。她说可以。回家的路上，我伸手摸了摸脸颊上的那道长长的紫色伤疤。我捏着边缘，在指间用力把它掐成白色。那道伤疤在我的脸颊上是麻木的，毫无生气且坚硬，就像一张课桌底下的一团口香糖。
Thanks to ice cream guy, I realized that redness didn't mean I was healing anymore. It meant that I was disfigured. I understood that I wasn't going to get much better. Despite all the reassuring things Tina had said to me in the burn unit, this was it.
多亏了那个冰淇淋小伙子，我意识到红色不再意味着我在愈合。它意味着我毁容了。我明白了，我不会好转太多。尽管蒂娜在烧伤病房对我说过所有让人安心的话，但这已经是全部了。
Ice cream boy saw me for what I was, scarred. All I wanted then was to go back to the hospital. I wanted to climb into my mechanical bed and watch Regis and Kathie Lee for the rest of my life. I wanted to eat chocky pudding and flirt with the nurses. I wanted to be able to scream.
冰淇淋男孩看出了我的真实样子，伤疤。那一刻，我只想要回到医院。我想爬进我的机械床，余生都看雷吉斯和凯西·李的节目。我想吃巧克力布丁，和护士们调情。我想能够尖叫。
When we got back to the hospital, Tina walked me to the elevator, and we rode up to the third floor. We hadn't said anything on the ride back. She never asked me how I liked the ice cream, which is good because I wouldn't have known what to say. Right before the doors opened, she put her hand on my forehead. I looked at her, and she said, good night, beautiful. And I walked back to the burn unit, the safest place in the world.
当我们回到医院时，蒂娜把我送到电梯口，我们一起乘电梯到三楼。回去的路上我们一言未发。她从未问我喜不喜欢冰淇淋，这很好，因为我不知道该说什么。就在门打开之前，她把手放在我的额头上。我看着她，她说：“晚安，漂亮的。”然后我走回了烧伤病房，那是世界上最安全的地方。
My name is Tina Bobo, and I am a nurse. And I worked at Children's National Medical Center in Washington, DC for about eight years as a burn nurse there.
我叫蒂娜·博博，我是一名护士。我在华盛顿特区的国家儿童医疗中心担任了大约八年的烧伤科护士。
How old were most of the kids who were there?
那里的孩子大多多大？
Well, primarily the kids that we saw there were toddlers, because children have thinner skin than adults do, so an injury, a cup of coffee from a microwave would severely burn a young child, whereas for you it might make just some redness and maybe a blister.
嗯，我们看到的主要是幼儿，因为孩子的皮肤比成人的薄，所以一次意外，一杯微波炉里的咖啡就会严重烫伤幼儿，而对你来说可能只会造成一些红肿，也许起个水泡。
Actually, as you say this, I'm picturing little kids' skin, where you can see all the capillaries on the surface. You can just see the blood moving through it in a way, where--
其实，你说这话时，我脑海中浮现出小孩子的皮肤，你能看到表面所有的毛细血管。你可以看到血液在里面流动的方式，在哪里……
This is much thinner.
这个薄得多。
Now, you were in the unit for eight years?
现在，你在那个病房待了八年？
Mmm-hmm.
嗯。
How often would you take a patient to go and get ice cream?
你多久会带一个病人出去吃冰淇淋？
Once in eight years.
八年里就一次。
Really? I should say here that you are the nurse in Brent's story, and we tracked you down. You live here in Chicago now. And I'm surprised to hear that he was the only one. Somehow, when I heard his story, I thought, oh, well, this is a nurse who, like, at some point, in her arsenal of tricks to help a kid keep a good attitude and get better, she'll just do the ice cream thing at some point.
真的吗？我应该在这里说明一下，你就是布伦特故事里的那位护士，我们把你找到了。你现在住在芝加哥。我很惊讶听到他是唯一的一个。不知怎么的，当我听到他的故事时，我想，哦，好吧，这一定是一位护士，她在帮助孩子保持良好心态和好转的技巧储备中，会在某个时刻就带孩子吃冰淇淋。
No. I wanted to do something for him. I wanted to do something outside the hospital with him.
不。我想为他做点什么。我想带他去医院外面做点什么。
Why? Why him?
为什么？为什么是他？
Because he and I had developed a very strong bond over those few months. We spent-- you know, I worked day, during the day, so I was there during most of the waking hours. The one thing, too, that was so special about Brent was that he was an adolescent. I identified. I was still very young. I was in my early 20s to mid-20s, which was very young, and you can't help but feel-- I don't want to say sympathy, but it is sympathy. I felt sorry for him. I really did. And so I wanted to do something to make his life better.
因为他和我在那几个月里建立了非常牢固的纽带。我们度过了……你知道，我上白班，大部分清醒时间我都在那儿。布伦特最特别的一点是，他是一个青少年。我产生了共鸣。我当时还是很年轻。我二十出头到二十五六岁，那非常年轻，你忍不住会感到——我不想说同情，但确实是同情。我为他感到难过。我真的很难过。所以我当时想做点什么让他生活得更好。
It must have been strange when you took him into the outside world and then there are the two of you, and you're not in your nurse's uniform, and he's not the patient. And there you are--
当你把他带入外部世界，你们两个人在一起，你没有穿护士制服，他也不是病人，那种感觉一定很奇怪。你就那样……
Feeling like I was supposed to protect him, and feeling very uncomfortable with that, because you can't-- I couldn't prevent what people were going to say or how they were going to look at him. And I couldn't control how he was going to feel.
觉得我应该保护他，但对此感到非常不安，因为你不能……我无法阻止别人会说什么，或者他们会怎么看他。我也无法控制他的感受。
On these trips, do you remember noticing other people reacting to Brent and him noticing them reacting?
在这些行程中，你记得注意到其他人对布伦特的反应，以及他注意到他们的反应吗？
Oh, certainly. I remember in the ice cream shop in particular, even the people who worked in the ice cream shop staring at him. And I remember being just really nervous that someone might say something that would really hurt his feelings, or stare for a prolonged period of time, or have some strange expression or something from seeing him.
哦，当然。我记得在冰淇淋店里，甚至连店员都在盯着他看。我记得我当时非常紧张，担心有人会说出伤害他感情的话，或者长时间盯着看，或者因为看到他而露出奇怪的表情。
The thought must have flashed through your mind at some point when you were out with him that maybe he thought of this as a date.
当你和他外出时，你脑海中一定闪过一个念头，认为他可能把这看作是一次约会。
You think? Well, not really. He was only 14. It never-- not really, no. I didn't think of it that way at all. It was just a really special friendship and bond that I had with him. But I didn't think of it that way. I don't know. Did he think of it that way?
你这么觉得？嗯，其实没有。他才14岁。这从来没有……其实没有，不。我根本没往那个方向想。那只是我和他之间非常特别的友谊和纽带。但我没那么想。我不知道。他当时是那么想的吗？
I think, yes. I think the thought went--
我认为，是的。我想这个念头……
Really?
真的吗？
--through his mind that, well, maybe. Yeah, kinda.
……划过了他的脑海，好吧，也许吧。是的，有点。
Really? I'm just so flattered. He-- Wow. Well, I hope that was in some way beneficial to him to think that an older women with, you know-- and maybe that helped somewhat with his self-image. And I hope that's not a disappointment to him if he hears that it wasn't that way. But it doesn't mean that I didn't care about him any less. It just was very different.
真的吗？我太受宠若惊了。他……哇。好吧，我希望如果他认为一个年长的女性能以某种方式对他有帮助，这对他的自我形象会有所提升。如果他听到其实并不是那样，我希望那不会让他失望。但这并不意味着我不关心他。这只是非常不同。
You know, when you think about becoming a nurse, I would imagine the picture in your head is, you're going to be caring for people and helping them through this really hard time. And part of that picture must be that certain people you'll get close to and you'll really help them and be this person for them. How often do you get to feel that connection? I mean, would you actually accomplish it every day?
你知道，当你想到成为一名护士时，我想你脑海中的画面是：你会照顾别人，帮助他们度过这段非常艰难的时期。而那幅画面的一部分一定是，你会和某些人变得亲近，你真的会帮助他们，成为那个对他们很重要的人。你多久能感受到那种联系？我是说，你每天都能做到吗？
No, you don't. In reality, you don't. You don't make those kind of bonds on a-- I can think back, of all the children I took care of-- and there was probably thousands of children-- and I remember distinctly probably 20 of those thousand in that eight years. And again, that was a special place, because it was all children, and it was a place where we had such great resources and wonderful people. It seems like, because back then, resources for health care weren't like it is now, so it was kind of like an ideal world then. And every time I think back, oh, I wish I had that kind of job again. But that doesn't exist anymore. Wonderful place.
不，不能。实际上，你做不到。你不会和……我回想起我照顾过的所有孩子——可能成千上万个孩子——在那八年里，我能清楚地记得大概20个。再说一次，那是一个特别的地方，因为它全是孩子，而且我们拥有如此丰富的资源和很棒的人。看起来，因为那时医疗保健的资源不像现在这样，所以当时就像一个理想世界。每当我回想起来，我都会想，噢，我真希望再有那样的工作。但那种工作已经不存在了。多么棒的地方。
You're saying, literally, like, places like that don't exist?
你是说，确实像那样的地方已经不存在了？
I just can't find it if it's out there.
如果外面有，我只是找不到。
This is just 10 years ago or something.
这仅仅是十年前或什么的。
I know, but--
我知道，但是……
It's changed that much?
改变有那么大吗？
--things are so dramatically different, just in terms even of staffing. Today, because there's such restraint issues with money, it seems as if staff are kind of in opposition with administration. And hospital, it just doesn't seem cohesive. Back then, it was just, the whole hospital, it just felt this cohesiveness. And I've been back, it's very different. In fact, the burn unit doesn't exist there anymore. Things are so different now than they used to be.
……情况完全不同了，仅仅就人员配置而言。今天，由于金钱的限制，员工似乎和行政部门是对立的。医院看起来不再是一个整体。那时候，整个医院，就感觉有一种凝聚力。我又回去过，非常不同。事实上，烧伤病房已经不在那里了。现在的事情和过去太不一样了。
I remember thinking that something had changed in America when I saw this movie, that was not a very good movie, called As Good As It Gets last year. It was Jack Nicholson and-- what's her name? Helen Hunt.
我记得去年看那部不太好的电影《尽善尽美》时，我想到美国发生了一些改变。那是杰克·尼科尔森和……叫什么名字来着？海伦·亨特。
Helen Hunt, right.
海伦·亨特，对吧。
And I realized, god, something has happened in America if you can have a movie and the heroic thing that the guy does is get the kid off the HMO and get him to a private doctor, like that's the heroic act.
我意识到，天哪，如果有一部电影，电影主角做的英雄壮举是让孩子离开健康维护组织（HMO）并带他去看私人医生，就像那是一种英勇行为，那说明美国一定发生了一些事情。
Right. It was incredible, right?
没错。那太不可思议了，对吧？
Uh-huh.
嗯哼。
Kind of like Santa Claus, almost.
几乎就像圣诞老人一样。
Well, no, like, people clapped. You know what I mean? I was like, what has happened in this country that, like, just getting somebody out of regular health care can be, like-- Did you see this movie? Do you know what I'm talking about?
好吧，不是，就像人们鼓掌一样。你知道我的意思吗？我当时想，这个国家发生了什么，竟然只是让某人脱离常规医疗护理，就能成为……你看这部电影了吗？你知道我在说什么吗？
Oh, sure. I've seen it, like, two or three times.
哦，当然。我看过两三次了。
And did it strike you too? The fact that, like, what's going on here?
它也让你印象深刻吗？事实上，到底发生了什么？
Well, for me, it wasn't so amazing because I know, well, that is a big deal. My husband was just like, who cares? OK, fine. The kid got to go see a good doctor. I was going to say one more thing.
嗯，对我来说，这并不那么神奇，因为我知道，嗯，那是一件大事。我丈夫就觉得，谁在乎呢？行，没问题。那个孩子能去看个好医生了。我想再说一件事。
Say it.
说吧。
[SIGHS] I remember, when I would do Brent's wound care, I felt like, because it was difficult to make an emotional detachment, oftentimes I felt like I didn't do a very good job doing that, because it was hard to push myself to do something that I knew was going to hurt him so badly. I'm not sure that was necessary to his benefit. I'm not saying it caused him any harm, but it was difficult to do.
[叹息] 我记得，当我为布伦特做伤口护理时，我觉得因为很难做到情感疏离，我经常觉得我做得不是很好，因为很难迫使自己去做一件我知道会让他如此痛苦的事情。我不确定那对他有什么好处。我不是说那对他造成了伤害，但真的很难做。
It's so interesting talking to you, that even now when you think about it, you worry that you went too far and got too close.
和你交谈真有意思，即使现在回想起来，你还会担心自己做得太过火，靠得太近。
Mmm-hmm. I often wonder if that was beneficial to me at that time, too. It didn't make my life easy. When I talked to Brent, he asked me--
嗯哼。我经常怀疑那对我当时是否有益。那并没有让我的生活变得容易。当我与布伦特交谈时，他问我……
When you talked to him just recently?
当你最近和他交谈时？
When I talked to him just recently, he was telling me that what he had written, the story that he had written, and he basically said, one of his big questions, he would lie in his bed and wonder what the heck I was doing when I left his bedside. Like, why isn't she in here? I'm going through all this pain. I am totally alone. Someone should be with me. Why isn't she in here? What is she doing?
当我最近和他交谈时，他告诉我他所写的，他写的那个故事，他基本上说，他的一大疑问是，他躺在床上会想，我离开他的床边时到底在干什么。就像，她为什么不在这里？我正经历着所有的痛苦。我完全孤身一人。应该有人陪我。她为什么不在这里？她在做什么？
And it was important for me to get away, too. Like, after I had been through that with him, I needed to kind of cleanse myself, too, of-- you know, get myself together. That was one very difficult thing for me to go through, too. Do you know what I mean?
而对我来说，离开也很重要。就像，在他经历了这一切之后，我也需要净化一下自己……你知道，让自己平复下来。那也是我经历过的非常困难的事情。你知道我的意思吗？
Yeah.
是啊。
It affects you. It's not like you can just shut it off when you come home. You're supposed to be able to, and most of the time you can. But in a situation like that, it's impossible.
这会影响你。并不是说你回家就能关掉它。你本应该可以的，大部分时间你也能。但在那种情况下，那是不可能的。
But in a way, if you think about the kind of nurse you'd want to have, you'd want the nurse who would be affected by it outside of the hospital.
但从某种意义上说，如果你想到你想要的护士类型，你会想要那种会被医院之外的事情所影响的护士。
Mmm-hmm. You would, if it were you, if it were me.
嗯哼。如果是你，如果是我的话。
But you're saying, from a nurse's perspective, that it's too much to ask a person to do, it's too much to ask a nurse to do. It's just like, as the health care provider, you have to be able to have your own life or you'd go nuts.
但从护士的角度来看，你是在说这要求一个人做的事情太多了，这要求护士做的事情太多了。就像作为医疗服务提供者，你必须有自己的生活，否则你会疯掉。
You do. You have to be able to separate.
确实如此。你必须能够分开。
Tina Bobo. Brent Runyon's story was produced by Jay Allison as part of his Life Stories series, with help from Christina Egloff and funding from the Corporation for Public Broadcasting.
蒂娜·博博。布伦特·鲁尼恩的故事是由杰·艾利森制作的，作为他“生活故事”系列的一部分，由克里斯蒂娜·埃格洛夫协助，并获得了公共广播公司的资金支持。
[MUSIC - "SAY YES" BY ELLIOTT SMITH]
[音乐 - “答应我”，艾略特·史密斯]
Act Four, Looking For Love in all the Wrong Places. So what if you don't obey the rules and customs of the hospital? Wendy Dorr has this story of one woman who did, over and over, disobey those rules, and what happened to her.
第四幕《在所有错误的地方寻找爱》。如果不遵守医院的规则和习俗会怎样？温迪·多尔讲述了这个故事，一位女性反复地违反规则，以及她发生了什么。
The first time Wendy Scott went into a hospital, she was 15. She had her appendix out. And she was surprised how much she enjoyed it. This was back in her hometown of Wemyss Bay, Scotland.
温迪·斯科特第一次住院时是15岁。她切除了阑尾。她很惊讶自己竟然那么享受住院。那是在她苏格兰威姆斯湾的老家。
I enjoyed it when the nurses would come and fluff up my pillows and ask me how I was, and how was the night, show a little bit that they cared, which is something I never really had at home.
我享受护士来拍松我的枕头，问我感觉如何，晚上过得怎么样，表现出一丝她们在乎，这对我来说是在家里从未得到过的。
A year later, feeling depressed and alone, working at a holiday camp on the east coast of Scotland, she got the idea to walk herself into an emergency room and tell them that she was feeling sick when she wasn't.
一年后，在苏格兰东海岸的一个度假营工作时，她感到抑郁和孤独，产生了一个想法：走进急诊室，告诉他们她感觉生病了，虽然她并没有病。
I knew I wasn't sick, but I wanted somebody to care about me. They kept me in a few days. They did a few blood tests, a few X-rays, said you're fine, you can go home. For a long time, that was all it ever was, which suited me. I mean, they took me into hospital, they cared about me, they gave me the attention I wanted. If you like, they recharged my batteries, and I was able to go back out and face the world and try and be normal again for a while.
我知道我没病，但我想要有人关心我。她们留我住了几天。她们做了几次验血、X光检查，说我很好，可以回家了。很长一段时间里，仅仅是这样，这正合我意。我是说，她们让我住院，她们关心我，她们给了我想要的关注。如果你愿意，她们为我充电，我又能够回到外面面对世界，试着再次正常生活一段时间。
In the same way that prison can be the best place to learn how to become a better criminal, in hospitals Wendy learned how to become a better invalid. Over time, she came up with her own set of rules. Number one, always pause after the doctor asks you a question. It makes it look like you're thinking about the answer. Number two, never change your story. Number three, when all else fails, tell the doctor you have a stomach ache. They can't prove you don't, and stomach pain can mean 100 different things. Number four, listen closely to what the doctor says. He'll tell you everything you need to know.
就像监狱可以成为学习如何成为更好罪犯的最佳场所一样，在医院里温迪学会了如何成为一个更好的“病人”。久而久之，她总结出自己的一套规则。第一，医生问问题后总要停顿一下。这看起来像你在思考答案。第二，永远不要改变你的故事。第三，当一切方法都失效时，告诉医生你肚子痛。他们无法证明你没有，而腹痛意味着100种不同的可能。第四，仔细听医生说的话。他会告诉你你需要知道的一切。
Doctors taught me most of what I know. I mean, I would go into the emergence room saying I've got a stomach ache, and they would examine me, and then they'd say, have you got Crohn's disease? No, what's Crohn's disease? And then they'd tell you all but Crohn's disease and how it affects people and things. And of course, you're lying there taking all this in, ready for the next time you might want to use it.
医生教会了我大部分我知道的事情。我是说，我会走进急诊室说我腹痛，他们会检查我，然后他们会说，你得过克罗恩病吗？我说没有，什么是克罗恩病？然后他们会告诉你关于克罗恩病的一切以及它是如何影响人的等等。当然，你躺在那里把这一切都记在心里，为下一次你可能想用它的时候做准备。
Wendy claims to have been a patient 850 times at over 650 different hospitals all over Europe and Great Britain. It's hard to confirm these stats, as nearly all her hospital visits were registered under different names, names she'd randomly chosen out of the phone book. What she had was a psychological disorder called Munchausen syndrome.
温迪声称在欧洲和英国的650多家不同医院当过850次病人。很难证实这些数据，因为她几乎所有的住院记录都是用不同的名字登记的，这些名字是她从电话簿里随机挑选的。她患有一种叫做“孟乔森综合征”的心理障碍。
People with this syndrome go to extreme measures pretending to be sick just to get attention. And it's shocking how successful some of them can be. There are cases of people having amputations of one or more limbs, performed by doctors who believed they were ill.
患有这种综合征的人会采取极端措施假装生病，仅仅是为了得到关注。而且其中一些人的成功程度令人震惊。有些病例是医生因为相信病人有病，而进行了截肢手术。
I mean, I've had 42 abdominal operations on my stomach. And I never wanted them, but if I've gone to a hospital and the doctor comes and says he doesn't know what's causing this stomach ache and maybe he better have a look and see, if I say no, he's going to wonder why I don't want to find out what's causing this pain that I'm supposed to have. And so you go ahead and you have the operation.
我是说，我的腹部做过42次手术。我从没想要过它们，但如果我去了一家医院，医生走过来说他不知道是什么导致了这种腹痛，也许他最好看一看检查一下，如果我说不，他就会怀疑我为什么不想找出是什么导致了我本应有的这种疼痛。所以你就继续，做了手术。
Sometimes, during the operation, the staff would realize that she was faking it. And then she'd be stuck in the hospital, recovering from her surgery with everyone knowing she lied. Twice, she was even sent to prison, charged with illegally obtaining drugs, food, and lodging. The hospital, like any other ecosystem, has a set of rules, and there are certain rules you simply can't break and survive in the system.
有时，在手术过程中，医护人员会意识到她在假装。然后她就会被困在医院里，从手术中恢复，而每个人都知道她撒了谎。她甚至两次被送进监狱，被控非法获取药物、食物和住宿。医院像任何其他生态系统一样，有一套规则，有些规则是你根本不能违反且能存活下来的。
For 12 years, Wendy lied to doctors and nurses and shuttled from hospital to hospital. It was all she did with her life between the ages of 16 and 28, she says. She never held a job or had any close relationships. It was just too risky. As a result, her name and photo were permanently included in hospital blacklists all over the UK and Europe. Hospital blacklists are illegal here in the US, but not in countries with nationalized health plans.
12年来，温迪欺骗医生和护士，辗转于各个医院。她说，这成了她16岁到28岁之间生活中唯一做的事情。她从未有过工作，也没有建立过任何亲密关系。这太冒险了。结果，她的名字和照片被永久列入了英国和欧洲各地的医院黑名单。医院黑名单在美国是非法的，但在拥有全民医疗计划的国家却不是。
Finally, when she actually got her wish and needed hospitalization, she couldn't get medical care. About 18 months ago, she started to feel a pain in her groin while she was driving.
最终，当她真正有了住院的需求时，她却无法获得医疗护理。大约18个月前，她在开车时开始感到腹股沟疼痛。
I saw a surgeon and, well, he poked me around. And he said he couldn't feel a lump in my groin. And as for the pain I had in my stomach, well, that was payment for my past and I just had to put up with it. Payment for my past. And I just sat there in tears.
我找了一位外科医生，嗯，他检查了我一番。他说他没在我的腹股沟摸到肿块。至于我肚子里的疼痛，好吧，那是对我过去的报应，我只能忍受。对我过去的报应。我只是坐在那里流泪。
She finally got medical attention through a doctor she'd met on the internet a couple of years ago. Doctor Marc Feldman is an expert on Munchausen syndrome. And Wendy contacted him through his website after she started a Munchausen support group in London. Two and a half years and 100 emails later, they were friends. Wendy phoned him this past summer for advice about this pain she'd been having, so Doctor Feldman invited her to his hospital.
她终于通过她在互联网上认识的一位医生获得了医疗护理。马克·费尔德曼医生是孟乔森综合征方面的专家。温迪在伦敦创办了一个孟乔森支持小组后，通过他的网站联系了他。两年半，一百封电子邮件之后，他们成了朋友。去年夏天温迪打电话向他咨询她一直有的这种疼痛，于是费尔德曼医生邀请她到他的医院。
When the doctors went into her abdomen, they spent about two hours just cutting through the scar tissue that had resulted from all of those abdominal procedures she had had in the past. But once they had done that, they found what they described as a tumor the size of a small soccer ball.
当医生进入她的腹部时，他们花了大约两个小时才切开过去所有腹部手术留下的疤痕组织。但一旦他们做到了，他们发现了一个被描述为大小如小足球的肿瘤。
People lie in all sorts of institutional settings, in schools, at their jobs, on loan applications at banks, but most of us don't lie in hospitals. And it's not because we're worried about wasting hospital resources or humiliating doctors. We don't lie in hospitals because it's just too frightening. We worry there'll be mortal consequences.
人们在各种机构环境中说谎，在学校、工作中、在银行的贷款申请上，但我们大多数人不在医院里说谎。这不是因为我们担心浪费医疗资源或羞辱医生。我们不在医院说谎，是因为这太可怕了。我们担心会有致命的后果。
And in Wendy Scott's case, there were, because she violated the rules of medicine and she couldn't get care for 18 months. And in that time, the cancer spread to the point where there was nothing that could be done to save her. Though doctors told her she had two years to live, she died this fall, just a month after our interview.
在温迪·斯科特的案例中，确实如此，因为她违反了医学规则，以至于她有18个月无法获得护理。在那段时间里，癌症扩散到无法挽救的地步。尽管医生告诉她还有两年的生命，但她在去年秋天去世了，就在我们采访后一个月。
I'm not proud of what I did, in that I spent many thousands of pounds, wasted hospital time and money, but I couldn't help it. It was something I had to do. I just didn't know any other way to get somebody to care. And although it wasn't exactly the kind of caring I wanted, it was better than no caring at all. So you accept it.
我不为我所做的事情感到骄傲，因为我花费了成千上万英镑，浪费了医院的时间和金钱，但我无法控制。这是我不得不做的事情。我只是不知道还有什么其他方式能让某人关心我。虽然那并不完全是我想要的关心，但总比没人关心好。所以你接受了它。
And in the end, Wendy got over her attachment to hospitals. When her illness got more advanced and she could've spent her remaining days on a ward, she instead chose to leave the hospital and spend the rest of her days at home.
最终，温迪克服了她对医院的依恋。当她的病情进一步恶化，本来可以在病房度过余生时，她选择了离开医院，在家里度过剩下的日子。
That story from Wendy Dorr.
那是温迪·多尔的故事。
Well, our program was produced today by Julie Snyder and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Susan Burton, Blue Chevigny, and Starlee Kine. Contributing editors Paul Tough, Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin, and Alix Spiegel, Nancy Updike, and consigliere Sarah Vowell. Production help from Todd Bachmann. Elizabeth Meister runs our website.
好吧，我们的节目今天由朱莉·斯奈德和我本人制作，亚历克斯·布卢姆伯格、苏珊·伯顿、布鲁·切维尼和斯塔利·凯恩也参与了制作。特约编辑保罗·塔夫、杰克·希特、玛吉·罗克林和阿利克斯·斯皮格尔、南希·厄普代克以及顾问莎拉·沃威尔。托德·巴赫曼提供了制作帮助。伊丽莎白·迈斯特负责我们的网站。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
To buy a cassette of this or any of our programs, call us here at WBEZ in Chicago, 312-832-3380, or visit our website, where you can order tapes or you can listen to our programs for free, www.thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
如需购买本节目或我们任何节目的盒式录像带，请致电我们在芝加哥的WBEZ办公室，电话312-832-3380，或访问我们的网站，您可以在那里订购录像带或免费收听我们的节目，www.thisamericanlife.org。本节目由国际公共广播电台（PRI）发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who will tell you that when he and I went out just last week for that drink, he'll say it was not a date.
WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责，他会告诉你，上周我和他出去喝酒时，那不是约会。
I didn't think of it that way at all. It was just a really special friendship and bond that I had with him.
我根本没往那个方向想。那只是我和他之间非常特别的友谊和纽带。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回归。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。